everyone for coming my name is Sanjay
I'm here to talk about constant time
programming in fact this is work that
I've been working on with a whole host
of fellow collaborators so before I get
into what constant time programming is
or what in fact is I want to talk a
little bit about timing side channels so
say you have a cryptographic routine and
it takes an encryption key
it takes some unencrypted plaintext
message and you want it to produce your
encrypted cipher text and what you don't
want this cryptographic routine to do is
leak your secret data so you don't want
it to leak your encryption key or your
plaintext message the issue is that if
it's not implemented carefully enough
the crypto routine could have my new
timing differences based on the secret
debt and an attacker that is clever
enough can measure these timing
differences and from those timing
differences extrapolate the secret data
and so one of the ways of combating
these timing side channel attacks is
through constant time programming just a
quick note when I say constant time I
don't mean that the program takes the
exact same amount of time to run every
single time it's a little bit of an
unfortunate misnomer what constant time
means is that the time that it takes for
such a program to run is independent of
the values of any secret data so I'll
walk you through an example of what
constant time programming looks like so
a little bit of background first on
cryptographic padding most encryption
algorithms deal with messages in chunks
called block sizes so if you have some
message and it doesn't fill out a full
block size when you encrypt it the
encryption algorithm is going to Pat it
out so that it fills a full block size
first and so when you decrypt it you
have that message plus you have a bit of
extra padding that was there just to Pat
it out to the block size so what we're
going to do is we're going to write a
function that removes this padding after
decryption so we're gonna write this
function it's going to check for valid
in this case pkcs7 style padding in this
style of padding each by
of patting holds the patting size so in
this example there's five bytes of
padding so each byte holds the value
five and we're going to have this
function replace each byte with null and
return the total padding length or if
there was invalid padding it will return
an error and the key here is that the
buffer content since they came from the
decryption routine the buffer content
should be considered secret and that
includes the padding values so here's a
naive first implementation in C I'll
walk you guys through this we look at
the final byte of padding to determine
the overall padding length and for each
of those bytes we're going to check
whether it's the proper value and we're
going to zero it out and provided
nothing went wrong we'll return the
padding value at the end so let's say
each iteration through the loop takes
ten microseconds so all in all this
function takes about 50 microseconds to
run but what happens if we have an
invalid byte of Patty in the middle of
this then we're not going to take the
full 50 microseconds to run we're going
to end up returning early and this an
attacker can look at this timing
difference and figure out whether or not
the padding was valid because if we
return early then there was invalid
padding this is known as a padding
Oracle and can lead to padding Oracle
attacks which can leak your secret key
so this is really bad and the problem
like I said is that we're returning
early in the middle of this function
based on secret data so what we're going
to do is we're going to rewrite this
function there's a host of essentially
recipes that one can use to rewrite a
program to remove these sorts of
problems so the recipe we're going to
use in this case is we're going to
create a new local variable and that
local variable is essentially a flag
instead of returning on an error we'll
simply set the flag to zero and at the
end of the function we'll check that
flag to figure out whether we should
return the padding length or if we
should return an error code and so now
even though there's invalid padding
we'll still go through all five
iterations so there's no longer this
timing difference based on whether the
padding was valid or invalid so that's
good but what if in
that of say five bytes of padding we
only had three bytes of padding then
we're only going to iterate over the
last three bytes and now we're only
taking 30 microseconds instead of 50 50
and so now there's again this timing
difference based on the amount of
padding and thus we're leaking the size
of the message which is more secret data
and the problem this time is that our
loop is based directly on this secret
padding length so we're going to use
another recipe to fix this and we know
in this specific pattie style that the
padding length has to fit inside a
single byte and so that means that
padding lengths can be at most 255 bytes
so what we're going to do is we're
always going to loop over the final 255
bytes of this buffer and we're going to
check whether or not we're in the true
padding zone or not in the true padding
zone and it's that way whether we have
three bytes five bytes or however many
bytes and padding we're always going to
iterate the same number of times through
the loop and so we no longer have this
timing difference based on the amount of
padding or so we think so if we dig into
this a little bit more in the true patty
zone we're executing the entire contents
of this for loop but when we're not in
the true padding zone we're falling out
of this conditional block and we're only
executing this much code and so it's not
really ten microseconds it's maybe
something more like nine and so again we
have a smaller but still a measurable
timing difference based on the message
size and thus based on the padding
length and the problem this time is that
we have conditional code based on secret
data so whether or not we're executing
code is based on some secret conditions
and this is where things start getting a
little bit ugly so to remove
conditionals you start having to use
these kinds of crazy bit hack codes I
don't don't bother trying to parse this
it's it's not worth it
but the the end result of all of these
bit hacks is we get the semantic
equivalent of the code on the left but
without any of the actual conditional
statements and thus no timing
differences and so now every iteration
through the loop does in fact take about
the same amount of time and we no longer
have any timing differences
so this is a final constant time version
of this code and you can kind of see the
process it took to get here so it might
make sense now but if you come back to
this in say here or if somebody else has
to maintain this code and figure out
what it's trying to do they're going to
look at this and they're gonna be like
what is what is this doing this it's
it's it's crazy it's hard to parse don't
know what's happening and and this is
the failure of constant time programming
is that stands right now you may be
thinking to yourself at this point well
why can't we do something simpler is it
really necessary to do all of this why
can't we just use the original naive
version and say implement a random sleep
and so for any each individual iteration
of this function an attacker wouldn't be
able to determine anything from the
amount of time it takes to run but if an
attacker can execute this function
multiple times they can just average out
the randomness and you're right back
where you started so random sleep
doesn't work you could also imagine well
what if we did something where we
execute for five bytes of padding and
then we sleep for whatever the
equivalent of the other 250 iterations
would be so we had straightforward code
and then we just sleep to whatever
maximum value the problem there is that
it's it's very difficult to determine
what the actual max value should be
especially with all of this underlying
hardware architecture bent branch
prediction things going on and so if
there's even a small timing difference
then an attacker can capitalize on that
so sleeping until some max value doesn't
tend to work out either and so you do
actually have to do this kind of crazy
bit manipulation as it stands right now
and so this is where we currently stand
with constant time programming you have
to mainly keep track of what a secret
what is public you can't use conditional
statements you have to be careful with
your looping constructs and there's no
real simple solution and as a
consequence as you can see it took us
multiple iterations to get to this point
it's difficult to write this code and
it's even worse for somebody that has to
come back to it at a later point and try
to maintain this and this is actually
something that happens in practice so
about a decade ago there was a timing
based padding Oracle attack found
against open SSL and this is a
screenshot of the
that was there to fix it the the code
after that patch the fixed version of
the code still had another timing based
vulnerability so if you've heard it the
lucky 13 attack this was an attack
against it was a timing difference found
in the code that was supposed to have
fixed the original timing difference and
even after this patch there were still
more timing differences and so it took
many years for them to finally fix all
of the different timing variations until
the code was no longer at the point
where there was no longer any more
timing variation based on secret data
but even then there was still a bug in
the code it was a padding Oracle it was
not a timing based padding Oracle
because there was no more timing
differences but it was a database
padding Oracle and the fix is literally
just this single line and all this line
is doing is checking that the stated
padding value does not exceed the
maximum possible padding value and it
seems really simple in hindsight but it
was buried among all of this other crazy
bit hack code that they were using to
remove these timing differences and so
it went
uncaught for three years and it took
somebody with a fuzzing tool to catch
that this was something going wrong so
in practice constant time code is
actually very hard to maintain and this
is exactly where a domain-specific
language can help step in so with the
domain-specific language you can
explicitly distinguish what is secret
and what is public have that
incorporated into a type system that
prevents you from writing leaking code
and we can even have the compiler help
you write constant time code allow you
to write something that's clear and
concise and have it transform it into
something that's safe and so this is
what fact is we don't imagine in fact as
a general-purpose programming language
it's meant to be a language where you
just write the functions you need to be
timing secure so if you have a
pre-existing code base you can write
your timing secure functions in fact the
compiler will produce a header file and
it'll produce an object file and you can
toss those right in to the rest of your
tool chain and it just fits easily right
in so what does fat code look like
so here's an implementation of that same
patty removal function that we were
going through at the beginning right off
the bat you might notice we have
explicit labels so the contents of the
buffer are secret the return value of
this function is secret and the
temporary variable we're using to store
the padding length is also secret so the
compiler will check that we're not
leaking any of these values we have some
basic memory safety so we're marking
this buffer as mutable since we're
zeroing out part of its contents and we
have a precondition that the buffer is
at least 255 bytes long since we're
going to be iterating over those final
255 bytes and most notably here we're
using conditional statements and we're
using a return statement smack in the
middle of this function and it's totally
fine because the compiler will realize
that this is something that needs to be
taken care of and we'll transform this
into constant time code and this is much
nicer to work with than that crazy
secret that we were doing before and
it's totally constant time and again
this is because we have the compiler
using labels and doing automatic
transformations so I'll go over those in
more detail the labels are there to
ensure that there is no leakage there's
no assignment from any secret data to
public variables there's no indirect
leakage of secret data based on control
flow or any other routes and we can use
these labels to prevent secret
expressions that may leak in an indirect
manner so like I talked about bounding
your loops with secret data this would
be disallowed by the fact compiler
because you're bounding your loop with a
secret value but if you're bounding it
with a public value that's totally fine
and inside of that loop you can have
some secret conditions so that you're
only doing things when you need to
if you index memory based on a secret
index that can lead to cache timing
attacks which can then reveal that
secret data so indexing memory based on
Secrets is also disallowed by the fact
compiler but indexing based on a public
value again totally fine so you could do
something where you loop through some
public indices and then again use a
conditional statement to select the
values that you want it's also the case
that there are
instructions in the architecture that
are that have variable timing based on
the operands so for example on x86 64
platforms integer division takes
different amounts of time based on the
operands so in fact we disallow division
based on secret values but dividing with
public values totally fine or if you
have a constant time division algorithm
you can use that as well there's also
the issue of recursion so recursion can
leak data just like a loop bounded by
secret values the amount of times you
recurse may be based on some secret
value in the fact language we just
disallow recursion entirely we haven't
found that it's useful in cryptographic
implementations we've looked at and so
it's easier just to have no recursion at
all fact is after all it demands
specific language not a general-purpose
language so we don't need recursion the
other part of fact is that we can
automatically transform this code to be
constant time so all of those recipes
that I was showing you where we rewrote
our code manually fact can apply these
automatically so for example if we have
conditional statements if we have some
assignments based on some secret
conditions we can transform those into
straight straight line branch free code
so in this case we'll set up these so
the code on the left is fact the code on
the right is pseudocode this would be
kind of internal to the compiler so it
would select between different values
based on these conditions we're folding
the control flow into data so if s and s
2 are both true then we will assign 42
into X otherwise we will assign the its
previous value back into itself
similarly if s is true but s 2 is false
then we'll assign 17 into X and if s is
true then whatever value X end-up ends
up as we'll add 2 and assign that to Y
and so the CT selects that pseudo
function can be implemented in an
efficient manner so on platforms that
support it like x86 platforms there's a
conditional move instruction that's
known to be constant time so we can
implement this selection operator using
a c move instruction on other platforms
that may not support this we can
use those same bit hacks that we saw in
the C code and so we have this primitive
that we can then use to conditionally
select values and keep things constant
time so this is one type of
transformation we do another type of
transformation deals with those early
return values so if we have a return
predicated on some secret condition we
can transform that such that we have a
new local variable that tracks the
current return value and we have a flag
that determines whether or not this
function would have returned and we
conditionally estate those values based
on what the current control flow should
be so if s is true and we haven't
already returned then we update our
return value with 42 and we set the
return flag correspondingly then later
down the line
if we haven't returned at that point
then we update the return value with 17
and we update our flag appropriately and
at the end of the function we return our
return value we can also have
transformations across functions so if
we have some function that could mutate
its arguments so in this case we have
the function foo that can update the
value of x and it's called inside a
secret condition what we can do is we
can transform the function call to take
this caller context so we pass the
caller context into the function and
then we update the function itself to
use this caller context whenever we need
to update one of these externally
visible variables so we get cross
function transformation as well so this
may seem fairly straightforward on the
face of it the transformations can be a
little bit subtle so in this example we
have the condition of eyes less than
some secret index than zero out the
corresponding index in the buffer but if
I is for example out of bounds for buff
conventionally because this is a
conditional statement we would guard
this execution and we wouldn't touch
memory based on I if it's out of bounds
for buffer because it would be greater
than whatever secret index but after
transformations we're always going to be
accessing this index I whether or not
eyes out of bounds and this could lead
to memory areas such as a segmentation
fault
and that's bad and the the issue is that
conditional statements after
transformation no longer guard execution
and this is something we have to be
careful of
so the fact compiler will disallow these
kinds of programs by setting up
constraints and checking whether after
transformations we still have these
kinds of errors so we can use a SMT
solver such as z3 to generate
constraints on our program as we're
checking them and check that post
transformation make sure that we don't
have any memory errors or any undefined
behavior so division by zero or shifting
beyond the width of an integer we can
check for that and we can check for that
knowing the semantics of secret if
statements and making sure that this is
still the case even after transformation
so we have a safe language we can also
guarantee that post transformation the
code is constant time the way we
currently do this is where we rely on an
external verification tool in this case
C T véra
so after transformations we take the
resulting code we give it to this tool
and it comes back saying yes you are in
fact constant time and so with this
guarantees of safety and constant time
you can drop this right in to the rest
of your code base and we have features
in the language that allow you to do
this very easily so the fat compiler can
generate header files with function
prototypes so that your C code or any
other code with a foreign function
interface knows how to call the exported
fact functions you can call external
functions from fact as well provided you
give the fact compiler and appropriate
external for the function you can even
pass complex data structures as long as
fact knows the proper memory layout for
the data structures so you can pass
trucks back and forth between different
functions and the coolest part is that
we have libraries for embedding fact
directly into other languages so we have
currently embeddings for Python and
Haskell so here's a snippet of Haskell
code with in line in line fact function
declaration and this would generate a
function choose in Haskell that you
could then use as a Haskell function
a constant time selection routine for
example so I've been telling you all
about how fact is super great in theory
but how is it actually in in the real
world so it must be efficient since
especially since we're talking about
cryptographic code and it has to be
actually usable since I've been harping
about how conventional constant time
programming is not very usable so we've
ported code from several major
cryptographic libraries and we've also
conducted a user study so I'll share
some of the results here this is the
performance numbers from one of the open
SSL decryption code pets this is the
same code path that had all of those
problems that I showed you earlier with
all of the different timing attacks so
that decryption path is what we measured
so this is measuring throughput so
higher is better at the very top you
have the conventional C implementation
and just barely below that is our fact
port of it where we took the C code
ported it to fact turned all of the bit
hack code into conditional statements to
make it a lot nicer to work with and
we're only doing a little bit less than
C we also did a complete port from
scratch where we reimplemented the the
whole code path in a nicer more modular
way so on smaller chunks we're about a
little bit better than half as fast but
we quickly catch up to the C code with
larger chunk sizes so it's very
promising we also have the performance
numbers for Lib sodium secret box and we
actually do better than the C
implementation and both encryption and
decryption in this case and the reason
for that is the C implementation in
secret box uses hand-coded assembly for
implementing one of the underlying
routines through the salsa 24 accessing
vector operations and so they're using
hand-coded assembly whereas in fact we
we expose vector types and vector
operations directly as part of the
language and so the vector operations in
fact we'll go through the compiler go
through the optimizer and we generate
more efficient vectorized code than
hand-written assembly so it's a win for
us here so mentioned we had a user study
we conducted this on an undergraduate
programming language class we had two
sets of problems for them to do we gave
them code written both in C and written
in fact and we had them write short
answer responses telling us what the
code is supposed to do and we also had
them write constant time code themselves
both in C and in fact based on some
specification that we gave them and the
results we found were really good so
students were better able to understand
fact code than the C code so when
looking at fact code they were more
likely to be able to correctly tell us
what the code was supposed to be doing
as opposed to the corresponding C
implementation when they were writing
code more students were successfully
able to write a fact implementation than
the corresponding C implementation in
constant time we also we allowed
students to submit programming for this
for writing code we allowed them to
submit multiple times and we logged what
kinds of errors that they had so if they
had syntax errors or type errors or
safety security errors so security error
would be there leaking a secret data and
students were less likely to get
security errors when writing fact code
we did also find that students were more
likely to get syntax errors though when
writing fat code and we chalk this up to
fact being a new language it's a little
bit different from C so they had to
adapt to that and we actually improved
some of the facts syntax based on the
results of this user study so this was
actually really useful to us the fact is
in actually a language in current
development so we have ideas that we're
still looking to implement so we have I
mentioned that we have vector operations
as a feature in the language we would
like to look at other cryptographic
routines see what additional features
might be useful to have in the language
maybe some add with carry primitives or
bignum operations or things of that sort
currently we're only focusing on the x86
64 architecture so targeting other
backends would be really great the arm
just came out with a new architecture
set that
as constant time instructions as part of
the architecture so that would be a
great thing to target there's also the
constant time web assembly specification
which I am also involved with which is
in addition to the web assembly spec for
constant time programming so you can
have crypto safely in your web browser
and we'd also like to verify the fact
compiler itself so prove that the
transformation is preserved semantics
and that they result in constant time
code without having to rely on an
external verification tool so that was
fact it's a domain-specific language for
constant time crypto code it transforms
your code to be constant time so you can
write it in a clear concise manner and
it fits directly in your tool chain and
it's fast and it's usable you can find
the source code for our compiler online
on github PL sis SEC slash fact and
it'll also link you to the other repos
that we have so the libraries for
embedding into Python and Haskell and
the the ported code that we have so
thank you
[Applause]
so have one question here so the
question is can you describe the methods
used in your user study a little more
did you do anything to control for
students programming skill so the user
study the way we had it set up is we
randomly divided students into two
groups so all students saw both versions
of a given problem so if both for
reading and for writing code they saw
both the C version and the factored
version but we had them randomly split
up between seeing the C version first
and then the fact version or seeing the
fact version first and then the C
version so that should have controlled
for any variation in programming skill
between any of the groups not seeing any
other questions on slide oh but if I
mean yes yes so we have we have four
loops right now we only have four loops
and we have four loops with only
monotonically increasing bounds so that
we can so that's to help the analysis so
we can check what range the loop
variable is in yeah
yes so this comes up a lot in C
programming especially which is one of
the reasons why we wanted fact separate
from the C language so the fad compiler
produces LVM code and we produce LLVM
code that to our knowledge the compiler
does not optimize back into branching
code so we were careful in what LVM
instructions were emitting so for
example there is an LLVM select
instruction that for 32 and 64-bit
values will produce the C move operation
but if you try to use select for 8-bit
values it'll produce a branch and so we
have to actually use inline assembly for
selecting 8-bit values so that we don't
run into that yes
yes that would be swell so at a another
conference that I was at I actually met
with somebody that knows some of the
LLVM devs and he passed along some
information it's something we want to
look into but we haven't been able to
reach out to them as of yet yes in the
back I am not aware of the rust constant
times stuff but we should
yeah not entirely sure what you mean
hey we should we should talk afterwards
but yeah yes
yes so right now the current version of
the language we only allow so we're
we're a little bit choosing how we allow
external function calls so you're not
allowed to make external function calls
within a secret context at all and even
with that it is possible that even
outside a secret context you pass it
some secret value and then it goes and
does its own thing that leaks that value
we currently don't have a way of
checking that external code plays nicely
and is constant time relying on the
developer to to know that essentially so
it's it's a kind of like a an escape
hatch for like if you have some really
low-level assembly implementation that
you don't want to rewrite in fact then
you can call out to that that's
essentially what it's meant for
and if there are any other questions but
if not oh yes
would mean by yes well so yeah so it
prevents time based leakages its memory
safe I'm not sure what you mean by if it
prevents mem copy various but yes so
yeah so that's going into the memory
safety issue so if the compiler can't
prove that your code is memory safe then
it'll fail to compile I guess along
those lines I should note that fact code
would not prevent you from Spector like
attacks we started this before Spector
blew up so it is possible to have code
that is constant time that is still
susceptible to specter attacks so that
is that is outside of our scope yes
yes yeah so like in fact our or
bottommost primitive is that CT select
essentially so however that is
implemented that being able to choose in
constant time between two values kind of
builds up the rest of the
transformations so you would need
something like that in whatever else you
were implementing this in so I guess
that's that thank you all for coming
thank you for the questions
[Applause]